aujourd'hui je suis désolé madame fin
vous n'êtes pas la maire de la ville de
sange est la mère du centre ville de
sens donc c'est regrettable
nous nous souhaitons la preuve c'est que
les comités de quartier ont été
supprimés nous souhaitons impérativement
remettre les comités de quartier et
travaille en priorité sur les trois
quartiers qui ont été totalement
abandonnée avec un taux de pauvreté là
pour le coup les chiffres de l'insee
je les connais par coeur j'ai pas besoin
de carte et 52% taux de pauvreté en deux
à rennes chaillot et ce en plein champs
plaisants avec la remise en place des
écoles de proximité et surtout pas cette
tendance à la ghettoïsation avec un
complexe scolaire que vous voulez créer
une cité éducative où on va manger les
petits c'est une super marché de
l'enfance comme je l'appelle
donc je suis foncièrement contre et
c'est au sein de l'arène du programme de
rénovation des champs-plaisants que je
souhaite réhabiliter la mjc non pas la
refaire veut la faire revenir la
réhabiliter parce qu'elle a montré sa
capacité à être un acteur de
l'agglomération